il faut comprendre que c'est important
de chiffre élevé puisque aujourd'hui des
données non chiffrée n'importe qui qui
aura un accès physique au match innocent
serveurs pour être copier les données
les exploiter quand les données sont
chiffrées si on n'a pas la clé de
déchiffrement ça rend beaucoup plus
complexe l'exploitation des données donc
effectivement c'est vital même qu'une
entreprise qui a des données
personnelles de quelqu'un les chiffres
pour au moins ralentir si des hackers ou
même des agences gouvernementales mal
intentionnées ou à sa forme de gens
veulent accéder aux deux ne puisse pas
le faire
on sait que l'aigle afat travail avec
les services de renseignement américains
il avait même la technique des canaris
c'est à dire qu'en gros il disait on
tournait rien jusqu'au moment il ne
disait plus qui permettait de savoir
qu'ils avaient été compromis nous
français si on a accédé à des données
par exemple du président de la
république ou de quelqu'un ce serait les
lois américaines qui gérait giresse a
donc on n'aura aucun moyen aucun recours
de nous protéger contre ça